we've been talking a lot about what
could happen between now in the November
election that could propel Donald Trump
to re-election now Trump is down
dramatically in a number of different
polls to Joe Biden we're going to talk
about it a little later
right now Trump is losing among women
Trump is losing young voters Trump's
losing older voters minority voters
Trump's strong group is middle-aged
white men essentially but things can
change very quickly and there's a piece
in the New York Times by two doctors
from the University of Pennsylvania
including Zeke Emanuel outlining a
scenario where Donald Trump could force
some version of a corona virus vaccine
into emergency use in October and
October surprise so to speak and propel
himself to re-election I would even add
an alternative which is Donald Trump
will take what is already a likely
scenario I mean we a lot of reasonable
sober roadmaps have said for months now
we are sort of expecting it's like a
50-50 maybe even more likely shot that
there's an emergency use of vaccine for
healthcare workers in the fall Trump
could simply try to take credit for it
despite the fact that he would have
absolutely nothing to do with such a
vaccine because dozens of vaccines have
been under development since before
Donald Trump was even taking coronavirus
seriously right now there are more than
120 candidate vaccines ten of which are
already in human trials we have phase
three trials starting in some of those
vaccines and from a mathematical
perspective it's likely one of these
vaccines is going to work and it will
have nothing to do with Donald Trump we
have already seen again the expectation
from some of the big financial firms
which think what you will about them
they tend to make analyses that are
based in fact many big financial firms
in thinking about the economic recovery
are expecting that by October there will
be some vaccine doses available for
healthcare workers and even if all of
that fails Donald Trump could try to
strong-arm the FDA to approve something
that's not really ready for approval
he'd need some pharma company
be complicit but the point of the op-ed
in the New York Times is this is not
completely inconceivable and it would of
course be very dangerous if it's not
actually the right time for a vaccine to
be approved but Donald Trump thinks that
he could get an electoral victory by
announcing I got the vaccine before
everybody else
open up businesses I fixed it let's go
back to work if that happened in mid or
late October it could generate just
enough confusion and craziness that
Trump gets himself re-elected assuming
he suppresses the vote enough in
November which is another aspect of the
2020 Trump campaign limiting the number
of people who end up voting so there are
a couple things that would be important
to understand if there were an emergency
use vaccine in the fall and I hope there
is it would in all likelihood only be
available to health care workers and
maybe by the end of the year we would
start to see more doses for some of the
most vulnerable Americans it would have
nothing to do with Donald Trump
whatsoever number two it is really
important to also understand that a lot
of these vaccines even predate this
coronavirus in the sense that there are
vaccines developed for poultry that have
been around for a while for coronavirus
in poultry that are being tweaked none
of this stuff would have anything to do
with Donald Trump but it doesn't matter
because it's all optics and what can he
take credit for and what's incredible to
see is since the start of coronavirus
we've seen anti-vaxxers spout
conspiracies about Bill Gates as the
reason why they wouldn't get a corona
virus vaccine or whatever there is now
in light of this op-ed there's a crowd
of people now who are Pro vaccine but
who were worried if a vaccine is pushed
out in September or October by Donald
Trump's FDA if it's approved by Trump's
FDA people are now legitimately worried
would it actually be safe because Donald
Trump has started to control all sorts
of regulatory agencies they mostly are
doing his bidding
Pro vaccine people are worried you know
if this is just a trumps
in October maybe it wouldn't actually be
a safe vaccine which is an incredible
thing to see and think about last point
I want to make from a perspective of
practicality Donald Trump has already
proven himself completely incompetent
and unfit to lead and what's happened up
to today justifies his immediate and
speedy removal from the office of the
White House whatever vaccine
developments happen between now and
Election Day would have nothing to do
with Trump and wouldn't justify his
re-election this is a really important
point
only people who want to get bamboozled
by Trump so they don't feel bad about
voting for him in 2016 and again in 2020
or just straight-up
ignorant people are going to fall for it
but unfortunately the 2016 election
proves that there are lots of people who
meet that criteria thus we have to get
out there and make sure we get every
single vote while we hope that a vaccine
is actually safely made available as
soon as possible very important note
nobody on the left wants people to die
nobody on the left once the economy to
fail to hurt Trump Trump has already
justified his immediate removal again if
he cures cancer and ends a climate
change by November come and talk to me
but his actions already justify his
immediate removal tonight join me for
the David Pakman show
chess tournament number two sign up for
free at david pakman.com slash chess
already over 300 people signed up to
play hoping for a thousand I'll see you
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern tonight don't miss
it